what does it mean for a matrix to be
positive we know since elementary school
what it means for a real number to be
positive for example 2 is a positive
number minus 3 is not but what about
matrices can we find a sensible useful
definition of what it means for a matrix
to be positive the goal of this video is
to show that the answer is yes
and make no mistake this new definition
that we will see is not simply a
mathematical curiosity in fact this new
definition has enabled a whole new field
of mathematics called semi-definite
programming with some unexpected and
frankly mind-boggling applications to
science and engineering
here are by order of difficulty three
math questions that we will attack using
this new notion the first question is
from geometry consider three unit
vectors x y and z and assume that the
inner products between each pair of
vectors is the same and let's call the
common value of this inner product alpha
in other words assume that if you
project x on y y on z or z on x the sine
length of the projection is the same
alpha another question is what is the
smallest possible value for alpha we
already know that alpha is between -1
and 1 and the following configuration
where all the vectors are orthogonal to
each other shows that alpha can take the
value 0.
so the minimum value of alpha is
somewhere between -1 and 0 but what is
it exactly
the second question is from dynamical
system theory given a square matrix a
can you tell whether the linear
dynamical system given by xk plus 1
equals a times xk is asymptotically
stable
that is can you prove or disprove that
for any given initial condition
if you keep multiplying by a you always
convert to zero
the third and last question i wanted to
show you is about finding good solutions
to np-hard problems
for example in the famous max cut
problem you are given a graph and you
want to cut the notes in two sets in
such a way that the value of this cut or
in other words the number of edges that
the cut goes through is as high as
possible
this is an imperative problem which
means that it is highly unlikely that an
efficient algorithm for finding the best
possible cut exists
can you think of an algorithm that finds
a good enough cut
or in other words can you find a cut
whose value is at least let's say 0.8 of
the value of the maximal cut i totally
can see that this is somewhat of a
question at this point but trust me the
solution technique is so beautiful that
it was impossible for me not to include
this question in this video
amazingly all of these questions were
used to find in a particular positive
matrix that satisfy some conditions and
if you're curious about this new
definition of matrix positivity and
you're wondering how it is even possible
to use this notion to tackle so many
different problems that are not even
about matrices in the first place then
this is the perfect video for you the
only prerequisite you will need is some
familiarity with the basics of linear
algebra if you know what a vector is
what a matrix is and what it means to
multiply matrices and vectors together
then you're good to go
[Music]
so how can we generalize positivity for
matrices as usual in mathematics to find
the right generalization of some concept
like positivity you need to look at it
from the right perspective sure we could
define positivity element wise we could
define a matrix to be positive if all of
its entries are positive but this
definition is not really satisfying
because it does not use the matrix
structure in any meaningful way what i
mean by that is that we could rearrange
all the terms in a column vector a row
vector or even in a box the definition
would still go through there is a much
more useful definition of positivity for
matrices and more specifically for
symmetric matrices that takes into
account the matrix structure
why only symmetric matrices you might
ask
well it turns out that with the
symmetric assumption the math just
becomes particularly nice and most of
the cases of interest in practice
involve symmetric matrices anyway so
what makes a matrix a matrix is not the
fact that it is a table of values but
rather it is the fact that it is a
linear operator that acts on vectors it
takes as input a vector x and spits out
another vector y equals a times x
to gain some intuition consider the
special case where the matrix a is one
by one that is a number
if a is positive for example equal to
two you can think of multiplication by a
as a stretch in operation
on the other hand if a is negative for
example -2 then you can think of
multiplication by a as a reflection
about the origin and then stretching
so positive numbers when you think of
them as operators are really the ones
that keep their output on the same side
as their input with this in mind we
define a matrix a to be positive if for
any non-zero vector x the vector y that
a outputs stays on the same side as x
in other words the inner product between
x and a times x should be positive and
to make it clear that we're talking
about positivity for matrices and not
numbers we will call such a matrix
positive definite if the inner product
between x and ax is only in a negative
we call the matrix a in that case
positive
semi-definite before we move any further
let's look at some special cases to get
a feel for this new definition
the identity matrix for example is
positive definite
this is because if you multiply the
identity from the left and the right by
some non-zero vector x you get x
transpose x which is the sum of the
entries of x squared which is positive
you can also directly argue that the
identity is positive definite because it
does not change its input so obviously
the input and the output fall on the
same side now let's take a look at a
diagonal matrix that is not necessarily
the identity to be able to tell whether
it's positive definite let's multiply it
on the left and the right by some
non-zero vector x
in this case we get the sum of the
diagonal elements times the square of
the entries of x if all the diagonal
elements are positive then its diagonal
matrix is positive definite if one or
more entries is zero then it is only
positive semi-definite
and if at least one of the diagonal
entries is negative then this matrix is
not even positive semi-definite and here
you might wonder if that
characterization is true for
non-diagonal symmetric matrices as well
to know if a symmetric matrix is
positive semi-definite can we just check
if the diagonal entries are negative
this is actually false for example this
symmetric matrix
has positive diagonal entries but you
can easily check that when you multiply
by the vector 1 1 from the left and the
right which corresponds to and this is a
good trick to know summing up all the
entries of the matrix
negative 2. so this matrix is not
positive semi-definite so it turns out
that the right numbers to look at are
not the diagonal elements but rather the
eigenvalues of the matrix
recall that eigenvalues are numbers
lambda that satisfy a times u equals
lambda u for some non-zero vector u
which is known as the eigenvector
you see for diagonal matrices the
diagonal elements are exactly the
eigenvalues but that stops being true
for non-diagonal matrices let's see
what's being positive semi-definite
means for eigenvectors and eigenvalues
by definition if you apply h1
eigenvector u it gets multiplied by an
eigenvalue lambda if lambda is a
negative you simply get scaled
and if lambda is negative u gets
reflected and then scaled
so the only way for matrices to be
positive some by definite is if all of
its eigenvalues are negative
the converse although we won't have time
to prove is also true if all the
eigenvalues are negative then the matrix
is positive so my definite
this new characterization is important
because it gives us one algorithmic way
of checking a matrix positivity it
reduces the task of checking whether a
matrix is positive semi-definite to
checking whether a bunch of numbers the
eigenvalues aren't a negative for
example the eigenvalues of this matrix
that we have seen before r5 and -1 which
is negative so this matrix is not
positive semi-definite
to recap what we have seen up to now we
have defined positive semi-definite
matrices to be the ones that satisfy x a
x and negative for any non-zero vector x
and we showed that this is equivalent to
the negativity of the eigenvalues
and note that this generalizes as you
would expect to positive definite
matrices
it's now time to put this knowledge to
good use so to end this video let's
reinforce our geometrical understanding
of positive semi-definite matrices by
looking at sets that are described by
matrix inequalities
and let's start with scalar inequalities
for example let's look at triplets x y z
that satisfy x non-negative y negative
zenith negative and x plus y plus z
smaller or equal than one these
inequalities describe a pyramid like set
you know you are dealing with scalar
inequalities because the faces of this
set are flat
moving on what if we look now at
inequalities that involve matrices of
size strictly bigger than one for
example for what values of x this matrix
is positive semi-definite
it's not very hard to check that the
eigenvalues of this matrix are 1 plus x
and 1 minus x so for it to be positive
sum indefinite we need x to be at least
-1 and at most one so a single matrix
inequality can be rewritten as few
scalar inequalities is this always true
is matrix inequality simply a compressed
version of multiple scalar inequalities
as we will see the next example that is
not true matrix positivity is a much
more powerful concept than just a mere
collection of scalar inequalities let's
look at the set of triplets x y z for
which this matrix is positive
semi-definite writing out the
eigenvalues in terms of x y and z is
possible but very cumbersome but for any
particular values of x y and z we can
easily check if the eigenvalues of the
corresponding matrix are non-negative or
not
for example for the triplet zero zero
zero this matrix has a single eigenvalue
equal to one so that triplet is inside
our set on the other hand for the
triplet two two two the eigenvalues are
the numbers five and minus one so this
triplet is outside our set and by
looking at all possible triplets we can
see what kind of set a matrix inequality
like this one can describe
and that's where things get interesting
triplets xyz that satisfy this matrix
inequality or geometrically the set
composed of all the green dots is called
an elliptop and it has some fascinating
properties
note in particular that its faces are
not flat so it cannot be expressed by
the usual scalar inequalities so
positivity for matrices is a true
generalization of positivity for scalars
and we will end things here for now but
stay tuned for the next video because
that's where the magic will happen
we will see how to use this set to
answer the first geometry question that
i presented in this video as usual if
you liked the video please like and
subscribe and see you next time